mon chéri de souris dur de garder sa
place la passe quoi sert elle voit plus
christine alors je dis quelque chose
d'intelligent et bien après ce tir et sa
part bon alors il va déjà déjà il ya une
erreur dans ta phrase à deux choses
d'abord sûr il ya 80% de marialles de
divorce à paris donc arretez de croire
que je crois mais il n'y a pas que paris
est vraiment on fera peut tout à fait
paris d'un sur deux ça prouve bien au
contraire
l'amour c'est scientifique c'est
chimique quand on couche avec quelqu'un
on sait très bien si ça le fera ou pas
[ __ ] et pour répondre à la deuxième
question qui est beaucoup plus
intéressante
moi je pense que quelqu'un qui est
artiste qui est curieux comme franck
dubosc
je pense que oui nous deux on pourrait
avoir un début davantage que des
mauvaises nouvelles se faire punir ses
locaux vides et a gentiment c'est parce
que ça aurait pu tomber juste à côté
non non et non et lancry series sont
promptes à plein les yeux
oui j'aime l'odeur de ta peau on a remis
ce thème sous la douceur de ton corps
j'aime tes cheveux ouais j'aime quand tu
parles ouais quand tu souris
ouais tu t'énerves way tes défauts sont
mes calibre même quand je te vire et
plus récemment j'avais peur du sexe donc
ça aide aussi bêta peut toujours je
pense qu'on fitr est extrêmement bien il
ya une connexion entre nous et cette
connexion serait également alors plus
générale mais c'est vraiment aucune
qu'on attend il ya deux secondes c'était
moi vous avez dit non
deux minutes excusez moi je n'ai aucune
collection parce que moi je suis
toujours en edge vous concernant excuse
moi et passer du coq à l'âne touché un
peu plus tôt chine